and welcome everyone for this cci
session this is the state of the union
for cci
really happy to have you i'm anthony
pasmart i lead our conversational ai
product at google cloud i'm really
excited about all the things we're going
to talk about
it's an exciting time because we are in
the middle of a revolution
it's a revolution of conversational ai
and conversational technology
ceos are already adopting the technology
about 31
of ceos have deployed conversational ai
platform
it's 50 growth year over year this is a
massive adoption of this technology
that has matured in the last few years
we're seeing that
customers by 2023 will prefer speech
interface to initiate self-service
70 percent of them said so this is a
rise from
40 in 2019 so pretty big change
uh and that same day 2023 about 40
of contact center interactions will be
fully automated by ai
this is a very big change too because
right now it's only about 25
it was was 25 a couple years ago
also a big change that is happening
customers and consumers of your product
are getting really familiar with the
conversational ai technology
this is obviously because they have
google homes they use search on their
android phone
90 of them are familiar with those
technologies and 72 percent have used
voice assistant
that means that consumers are getting
trained on those technology
they are getting more comfortable using
their voice to do something
uh to ask of uh google or ask of any of
their application
on a day-to-day basis there was a trend
in the past where we thought chat would
replace voice it's not happening
voice is growing very fast and ccai
is there to answer that call
so what is cci cci is really three
products inside google
uh we have dialogflow for automating uh
interactions and self-service
we have agent assist that is used to
help
an agent in a contact center deliver a
stellar experience
and we have a little newborn cci
insights which is in alpha right now
really helps you understand all that is
happening in your contact center
the cold writers etc so before we dive
into those products let's look at a
little video
to see what an experience could be with
contact center ai
hi priscia thanks for calling our bank
how can i help
hi i'd like to pay my bill great can you
please verify your address
15 state street oh and how much is it
virtual agent provides immediate
conversational support
with customers directing the flow you
owe 150
do you want to pay with the account
ending in 1337
yes please done i've sent an email
confirmation is there anything else
virtual agents can take care of basic
fulfillment on the spot
yes actually there's a 35 charge i don't
recognize
from last week it looks like it's an
overdraft fee
oh uh that's not fair i i didn't know
okay let me transfer you to a specialist
to help more complex cases are
seamlessly handed off to a human agent
hi priscia i'm elliot i see you're
concerned about the overdraft fee
yeah i didn't know i would get charged
okay i can waive the fee this time but
would you like overdraft protection so
it doesn't happen again
agent assist listens in giving real-time
step-by-step guidance
yes please okay i've set it up
is there anything else no this was great
thanks a lot lastly insights gives you
real-time visibility into key call
drivers and sentiment
so what you've seen here is an example
experience
of using first dialog flow for that cell
service experience
getting contacts helping the customer as
much as possible doing back-end calls
getting the information to them in order
to solve a problem
but when the call needs to be escalated
to an agent
dialogflow transitions very smoothly to
the agent
gives all the conversation context
anything that happened
so the customer does not have to you
know repeat again something very
frustrating for customer repeat
information re-authenticate themselves
do whatever
uh this is all taken care of by the
transition between diet flow and agent
assist
the is picked up right away the agent is
assisted in real time
no need for the agent to search on their
own they'll get the information
proactively thanks to agent assist
and then all the insights in the backend
are helpful for
coach qas product managers any person
in relation to the activities that are
going on in the contact center
we use that this experience is possible
because we have a fully integrated
product
it's an end-to-end solution for contact
center starting with
advanced conversational ai technology at
the core the text-to-speech
the speech-to-text and the nlu who are
powering the virtual agent for voice and
chat
as well as the human agent with
real-time prompts agent assist
and even dialogue for bots that can help
the human agent all of that
data being created all of those
interactions
are being fed into insights to have a
holistic view
of all channels and across the contact
center
and really understand what is going on
when we're looking at the value created
by contact center ai
we see two main lens the first one is
the human agent
how do we help a human agent with
contact scenario well by bringing those
suggestions uh to the human agent
at the right time with context
understanding of what's going on in the
conversation the
human agent will be faster will have
more accurate responses
will provide better information better
data will be relevant
and look very good look like a powerful
agent look like they know what they're
doing
and that's very important because the
human agent will feel empowered
they'll feel like a super agent and
that's a better
experience for the agent which means a
better experience for your customers
eventually
it will also reduce churn churn is a big
problem in contact center as you
probably know
between six months to 12 months for a
full contact center refresh
of of uh agents that's not good training
costs are hard
the skill level of agents is not perfect
with agent assist we can really help
that
solve that problem and make sure that
human agents can do a good job
right away feel good about their job and
provide the best experience for your
consumer
or the people uh calling in your contact
center
the second list are the cons the
customers the consumers
the constituents sometimes they get
self-service channels 24 7
through conversational chat bots and
agents this is great they can
really help their problem answers
whenever they're available for it
they have shorter call time with agents
uh
the agent knows everything after
transitioning from an ivr trade agent
the agent has all the information
they get the information faster the code
are shorter
the first call resolution rate increases
and the
brand loyalty as a consequence and the
trust into your branding to your
institution
your organization are greatly improved
so those two core sets of value human
agent and customer
are really what cci helps you deliver
and we really understand the challenges
that are common
across contact center you're seeing
ramping operational costs you're seeing
long average handle time you're not
having enough agent
especially in this time of a pandemic
where the demand is exploding contact
center cannot follow
they have to turn to technology they're
facing high turnover
costly training lack of visibility using
sampling to know what's going on in the
contact center
with contact center insights we can
solve that there's seasonality issues
they need to solve
really contact standardized fear is
there to solve all those problems
across your contact center challenges
a great example that happened actually
at the beginning of the pandemic
with the state of illinois unfortunately
many people have lost their job during
this dynamic
this is very bad and they had to file
claims for unemployment
and in the state of illinois they've
seen 3.2
million inquiries in the first two weeks
this is massive this is something
they've never seen before
how could they handle this they quickly
deployed
a contact center ai with an agent to
help them answer
unemployment claims they've handled more
than 2.6 million
voice and chat interaction through the
virtual agent
and have been able to answer 99.9
percent of clean claims in a timely
manner
the results is astounding very quickly
set up using partners like quantify and
cisco
and presidio they've been able to set
that up quickly
and serve their constituents in the
state that was a great success story
for them for us in a very difficult time
so let's look at the kcci offerings
let's focus first on dialogflow we
mentioned dialogflow was a self-service
tool
uh to build bots and make sure that
customers can
you know interact dialogflow has been in
market for a long time
it's been about three four years now a
transition was taken
more than two years ago to focus on
enterprise use cases
and contact center use cases thanks to
that
it's been deployed in customers like
discovery a financial services firm
markson spencer in retail
verizon for telco we have uh digital
native companies
uh other financial services fortune 10
retailer
for their employees usps if you're
calling for your passport uh that's
powered by dollar flow
the list goes on and on the adoption of
dollar for has been incredible
and especially in the last year and a
half two years we've seen a massive
growth in usage of dialogflow
you can see it in numbers 1.4 million
developers have signed up on the
platform
this is a massive increase from last
year uh
this is because we support up to 22
languages
there's more coming we have one click
integration with partners to get a phone
number
and a dialogflow bot behind it partners
like avaya genesis signal wire
you know box implant or early notes um
dialogflow can scale massive amount of
agents and intents uh 20 000
intense per agent that allows basically
if you simplify
somebody to call in and ask about those
20 000 things
for a single bot this is an order
managed bigger
bigger than most out there
dialogflow is keeping pci compliant and
is used in healthcare
and financial services as you've seen
and really we're seeing that enterprise
adoption
enterprise growth dialogflow becoming
the standard for building bots in an
enterprise
scale out on a price scale and today
we're really excited to announce
dialogflow cx
dollar flow cx is the next evolution of
dialogflow
this is all the learnings we've had in
the last few years
about what makes dialogue flow great put
it in place
to serve the enterprise market and the
complexity and the scale of
enterprise customers you're seeing here
a visual flow builder
this is one of the big asks that
customers have
how do we create complex flows with
dialogflow
backflow clx enables that you're going
to have a drag and drop visual flow
builder
with transition uh graphical transition
that you can just set up
and make sure that you can build bots
very very quickly it has native support
for
all the things that darfur had the 20
thousand intent per agent called mega
agent
the native support for sentiment
analysis at each turn
the custom voice support and i'll give
you an example of custom voice with
text to speech that's really exciting we
have ci cd pipeline
in the alpha cx which allows you to do a
b testing of bots and be able to have
two different versions
of the same intent and be able to test
their performance before you deploy
we have created an advanced nlu model
for the alpha cx
which is based on a massive transformer
or burke model
and outpour forms the previous nlu model
we had which was already a leader in its
market
we have better analytics and debugging
tool which are important
in large deployments because many people
are working on those bots it's not just
one person
and you need to have those debugging
tools and analytics tools
and very importantly we heard of
customers asking for
simpler pricing the pricing on the alpha
cx is based on sessions there's two
prices
a voice session and a chat session and
that's it
there's no consumption no time you know
how many queries you're doing
you have a voice session there's one
price you have a chat session there's
another price
makes it very easy very easy to know how
much you're going to spend without phil
cx
and we're really really exciting so
different cx is going to be better
is better today sorry and we'll go ga in
the next couple months
or a few months
let's focus now on agent assist agent
assist is all about
empowering human agents making sure that
human injuries are the most effective in
their job
as we know human agents are often time
new
maybe don't know the new products maybe
are not comfortable with some of the
information that the customers are
asking of them so what it does
it does a live transcription of all
calls and i'm saying
all calls in your contact center any
call coming through
is transcribed this is very new to a lot
of contact center
most contact center actually many do
call recording
but do they ever look at those call
recordings do they know what's in their
calls
not so much with the live transcription
you now have
transcription on every single call
coming in your contact center
and those calls are used and those
transcriptions are used to do
article suggestion and faq suggestion in
real time
we listen to the conversation give you
information
documents faqs whatever the cost the
agent needs
to answer a question will come in we can
also provide guidance through
a dialog flowbot if throughout the
conversation
about an intent mapping to a bot is
detected saying
i want to book a trip a buck can
probably handle that
you need a destination a date how many
people
et cetera et cetera the bot can guide
the human agent through all those
questions and make sure
uh the human engine is not missing in
this is really helping the agent be more
efficient
less time spent on the phone more
focused
because you don't have to put people on
hold and search and ask around for
different answers
and really makes the makes the new agent
more
aware of the grand taxonomy and whatever
terms the company is using and types of
answers the company
wants the agent to to provide to the
customer so a lot of benefits
agent is this was launched last year as
a voice channel
transcribing all calls and we've had a
lot of customers asking for that same
experience on chat
so i'm announcing today second
announcement agent assist for chat
agencies for chat does all the same
thing as voice we'll
do document suggestion if it keeps on
juicing but because you're on a chat
channel
you can do a little bit more so you can
do
smart replies and smart compose smart
replies are proposing several replies
possible replies that the agent can
click modify and send right away to the
customer
this is very helpful in a context where
agents have two or three
chats in parallel and they have to
switch context all the time
because of the smart reply they can go
to a window quickly see what kind of
replies they can send
and send them shorter time again more
accurate responses again
smart compose is what you've been used
to see in gmail for example or your g
dots
if you're typing it types ahead saving
time
reducing the number of typos having more
accurate responses
we integrated the same technology gmail
uses in the chat window
again efficiency for agents better user
experience
less training less training required and
low on boarding effort
a great launch very excited uh this is
really uh
interesting let's look at the third
pillar
cci insights in alpha right now
insights is about visualizing and
understanding what is going on
in context in your contact center
operations from
pure data just how many calls and
lengths of calls
but really drilling in the voice
conversation that's important because as
i said
you probably do record your conversation
but do you know what's being said
without doing just sampling sampling
will make you miss a lot of things
a lot of intents are not detected about
subjects a lot of topics are not found
especially if they're not that common
with insights
you can have topic modeler and like
really understand all the drivers of
your calls
but go to a conversation level and
really
see what conversation happened what are
the sentiment across conversation
drilling a conversation see all the
transcriptions
hear the audio if you're authorized to
do so and really understand what's going
on
you can do compliance check and qa
managers in particular
love this product because you can search
through the conversation and find all
the conversations that were not
good that they can really focus instead
of doing sampling and trying to find out
which ones were not good
it's very hard to do on audio only with
insights it's trivial
we're very excited about cci insights
still in alpha right now
but very quickly we'll go to beta uh it
does conversationality it's no session
reviews as i said
it's a complete solution that integrates
with the rest of the google cloud
platform
for example a native expert to bigquery
very important if you have crm data or
erp data or other database
that you want to ingest into bigquery
and map it to your customer
interactions in your contact center
insights allows you to do that
very easy to tie all that information
from your customer interaction
into the rest of the interaction with
your customers either your marketing
campaign your sales campaign
or whatever interactions you have this
allows you to really leverage the power
of google
and the power of the platform itself
and finally that search and query allows
you to find information within those
conversations very quickly
and really focus your effort to improve
your customer experience
so if we dive a little bit deeper into
each of the underlying technology
for the services the goal of google ai
is really to enable conversations that
are
as close to human as possible we're not
claiming that we're going to replace
humans
that's not the case but we want to be
close enough and actually we
advise our customers because you'll hear
some of the custom voice thing
we're going to advise our customers to
let people know that they're talking to
about
another human agent that trust is very
important
and we want to make sure that consumers
and customers are not deceived
by the experience we're providing with
google app we're going to ai benefits
from
deep research in our google ai team but
deepmind as well
but benefits also from a lot of the
google search
research that is happening lots of um
very very smart ai people uh doing
working on search
voice search uh working on the google
assistant working on the google home
even building specialized hardware for
ai or tpu
that you may hear here in other sessions
our tpu allows us to iterate on the
models
and the performance of those models and
do inference very very fast
enabling for example the speech to text
in
real time in streaming mode so with
those technologies underneath
we can create ai that understand what's
going on that can talk
and interact with the customers
if you think about speech to text in
particular the core
underlying technology for
conversationalism massive dictionary 120
languages supported
in the api you can bias the model
at each turn and actually that biasing
is used in dialogflow
which just by clicking one checkbox
can bias the model in each turn of the
conversation inside the iphone it's
called
speech biasing diaphragm knows the
context
speech to text can be biased based on
that context and automatically that buys
things done
which makes the intent detection
accuracy much higher
than if you don't use that biasing
that's fairly unique to google
we can detect several languages
formatting do real time
i'll spend a little bit of time on the
language report
many companies will claim language
support many companies will claim that
their model works best here and there
you have to be careful about models in
speech detects
you will need different models based on
the quality of the audio
based on who's on the line based on the
length etc
let's do a speech to text
for a long conversation a video
no subtitle very different audio
quality very different noise background
than an agent in a contact center
if you've been in a contact center you
know it's a very noisy environment
a little headset people are talking left
and right
it's it's hard and most people will call
from a phone
eight kilohertz quality two people are
talking on the line
very difficult if you apply the same
speech model
from transcribing a video conference
in a context of contact center that's
not gonna work
we have five languages optimized for
telephony
optimized for contact center spanish
english english us english uk
uh russian and i think we have another
one i can remember australian or
um something like that um those language
supports are very important because they
really make sure that the transcription
are done correctly that the document
suggestions are done correctly and then
the insights
you get out of it are done correctly
very important to
think about the optimization of the
models that you have
and what we can provide based on what
use case
the ivr model will be different from the
agent assist model and we provide
all of those for you in speech to text
innovation is happening almost
almost on a monthly basis pretty
impressive improvements
but today we're announcing a third big
move in conversational io
speech to text on-prem
future tech on-prem was a big ask from
customers especially in the financial
services
and healthcare what they really want
that processing of the raw
voice data done on premise before it
hits the cloud for other
types of processing for example a dlp
processing
a data loss prevention removing all the
pis from the test
now you can deploy speech to text
on-prem using nfs
which is our platform for the
multi-cloud and hybrid platform
you can deploy speech to text on-prem
and have exactly the same functionality
you would get
out of the cloud api the us english
support
multi-channel with several people
talking recognition the diarization
custom recognition of specific words
very important healthcare and financial
services as well actually
a lot of terms are specific to those
industries
and the noise robustness that is
required in particular
in contact center environment there's a
lot of background noise
etc so this is a super exciting launch
managing the on-prem deployment through
an iphone
console in the cloud so doing the
on-prem
the cloud way with the modern deployment
capabilities
the tracking the analytics and all the
good things you get out of nthos
now enabling speech to text to be
available for you on-prem
very excited about this launch
now let's talk about the other way
around when you have text and you want
to speak it out
we have been leading at google text to
speech
with several generation of technologies
the first one that's being used right
now quite a lot
is wavenet wavenet came from our
research arm
at google uh deepminds and
it's a voice that sounds fairly engaging
pretty close to a human voice much less
robotic than the traditional voice
you have 220 voices to choose from
female
male different tones and and speed
and 92 of them are wavenet voices across
32 languages
it is actually very easy to go test it
out you go on cloud.google.com
text to speech you can put a little text
choose your voice choose your language
and you will hear it stick very easy
i actually have a little bit of fun
myself i put for example
english and i take the french i put some
french in there and i play with the
little combination it's very interesting
to see what it does but it's pretty
impressive actually
so wavenet has been a great success uh
the text-to-speech api is very easy to
use through rest or grpc you can insert
you know pronunciation uh hints like
pauses and how to say certain numbers
obviously you're not going to say a
phone number the way you say
a dollar amount or a credit card number
or date so all those you can put little
uh hints in the text
for the text-to-speech api to adapt to
what needs to be said
one thing we're announcing today i
talked about wavenet and how it works
ray
we have now custom speech custom voice
it's basically the ability to train a
specific model
for a customer based on a human
voice actor and replicate that voice
actor's voice
for text-to-speech i can already hear
some of you say oh that
that's scary well the technology is
pretty impressive and you'll hear about
it
but we require an ethics review for any
deployment and access to this api
we want to make sure that customers are
using custom voice in an ethical way
and are not abusing the voice of an
actor
to do things that are not ethical so we
are gaining access to this uh
to this api through a review and when
you hear the example
i think you'll understand why so let's
listen to
uh two sample audio one is a human actor
saying a sentence and the other one is
the model
based on that human actor saying a
sentence that this
human actor never said let's listen to
the first one
the according to science direct
a flexed posture is characterized by an
increased thoracic kyphosis
obviously i'm not a doctor and i have no
idea what she said but um
it's interesting to hear her voice and
her pitch so now let's listen to
the bot version contact center ai brings
the best of google ai to customer
service
well you're saying i find it a little
fast so we could we could slow it down a
little bit
but the voice is clearly distinct and
clearly the same as the actor
that technology is available for
any customer following an ethics review
i want to use custom voice
inside dialogflow cx for example for the
ibr experience
or any kind of voice experience they
want
one customer was very keen on using
custom voice that customer is verizon
verizon has entered a digital
transformation of their contact center
experience
using the best of contact center ai from
google
and bringing to market an impressive
customer experience
throughout all their channels we'll look
at a video of sankar
as vp and cio of verizon talking to
thomas curran
our ceo about their expense why they
chose ccai
and what has been their success and
experience so far so let's listen in
today i'm here with shankar aru mugavelo
to talk about some of the work we've
been partnering on with verizon
how did you select our contact center ai
high fidelity synthetic voice that was
an important factor
the platform that can handle our scale
was critical in all these areas we saw
google cci
excel what does success look like so far
whether it is over a voice call
or a chat the natural language
recognition finds the best way to assist
them
in a consistent manner across all
channels
[Music]
we're so excited to collaborate with
verizon on this experience
verizon is really leading the innovation
in the space
has a massive contact center with a lot
of complexity and scale
that we were able to deliver
successfully to them it's a testimony of
our technology
it's a testimony of their innovation and
their trust in google
so i'm personally super excited about it
and the whole tvs
and they're going to be using a lot of
the technology that i presented today
the launch of dialogflow cx the advanced
nlu and visual builder
the stt on-prem which can be used by
financial services or healthcare
institutions
the chat assist which has been in high
demand and
being adopted very rapidly and the
custom voice
all those launchers are making the
google contact center ai
technology leading in the market really
getting traction and picking up the
largest contact center with the most
complex
use cases and the largest scale very
excited to be able to help our customers
solve their contact center experience
something really new
that was not really available a few
years back
and uh i love to be part of that journey
and i hope you're gonna need to engage
into that transformation yourself thank
you very much for listening to me
and i hope you enjoyed the rest of
google next